let's take Mora's advice and move away from using histograms. Up
to this point we've looked at distributions of single variables. For
example, friend count, and at most we looked at different subsets
of friend count by splitting it, using a factor, or in
our case it was gender. Now we're going to look at
two continuous variables at the same time. So, to get started,
make sure you're in the right working directory, and then go
ahead and load your data set and load the ggplot library.
Usually it's best to use a scatter plot to examine
the relationship between two continuous variables. Q plot chooses the
scatter plot automatically when we pass two continuous variables to
the x and y parameters, so let's go ahead and
do that. I'll pass age to the x parameter, and
I'll pass friend count to the y parameter, and finally
I'll indicate that my data set is pf, my pseudo
Facebook users. Now, there's over 99,000 observations in our data,
so when we create this plot, it might take a
few moments to render. And there it is. We could also
write this code which will produce the same exact plot. This
time, I'm not using the x and y parameters explicitly. And
that's okay, because qplot knows which variables to use on which
axis. X will come first, and y will come second. I'll
run this code, just so that way you can see the
same plot being produced. And there we go, we have a
pretty ugly scatter plot, but what are some things that you noticed, right away?